well our defense and security analyst
Michael Clarke is here well Michael this
is awful I mean utterly horrific that
this is happening in Europe in the 21st
century yes uh we've seen this sort of
thing with Isis the jihadist movement in
Syria and Iraq uh in the last few years
and this from all accounts uh looking at
the descriptions of what this video
contains which I haven't looked at uh
seems to have been a very Isis style
thing uh it's done with a short knife
took a long time to occur somebody being
held on the ground while it happened
um it's it's horrible it's not
unprecedented in the world sadly but it
is unprecedented in Europe and some good
advice out there online actually saying
that if you don't look around for this
thing don't don't look at it out of idle
curiosity or morbid interest unless
you're a professional unless you're used
to it don't look at it because actually
it will adversely affect you and that's
true with all of these awful videos good
advice
um what are the chances of finding the
purpose Traders uh the reasonable chance
of identifying the perpetrators because
as I understand it there's quite a lot
of forensic evidence available in these
clips but the chances of pinning it down
to a certain person but the unit that
might have been involved and the time in
which it took place seems to have been
during the summer there's quite a lot of
foliage around so this has been around
for a while and we do know that this
video and some others like it has been
circulating in military channels Wagner
channels certainly
um for some time it's only now popped up
on Telegram and it's now close to
Russian mainstream media and of course
there's all sorts of commentary and
mainstream media saying well this sort
of thing is going to happen and a good
thing too and so it's Unleashed a new
sort of level of mobility in this war
I'm afraid utterly hideous uh stay with
us uh Michael the ministry of Defense
has claimed that a leak of top secret
U.S documents suggesting UK's Special
Forces have been operating in Ukraine
display a serious level of inaccuracy
despite that U.S officials appear to
have confirmed the authentic city of the
files or some of them with the CIA
director describing the leak as deeply
unfortunate
the U.S Secretary of Defense said a
criminal investigation had been launched
into the league of the documents I was
first briefed on the reports of
unauthorized disclosure of sensitive and
classified material
on the morning of April 6th
and since then I've been convening
senior department leaders daily on our
response
and I've directed an urgent
cross-department effort
and we've referred the matter to the
Department of Justice
which has opened a criminal
investigation
now I can't say much more while the
Justice Department's investigation is
ongoing
but we take this very seriously
and we will continue to work closely
with our outstanding allies and partners
and nothing will ever stop us from
keeping America secure
Lloyd Austin there will the ministry of
Defense has said in a statement the
widely reported leak of alleged
classified U.S information has
demonstrated a serious level of
inaccuracy readers should be cautious
about taking at face value allegations
that have the potential to spread
disinformation
well as for Russia the Kremlin spokesman
Dmitry peskov has told Sky News Russia
had been aware of certain information
within the documents well before they
had leaked
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
forces UK's Special Forces among others
um what would they be doing in Ukraine
if indeed they are in Ukraine yes the
Minister of Defense neither confirmed
nor denies anything about Special Forces
and that's very sensible from their
point of view if they are there and it
may be according to the documents that
maybe 50 out of the 100 or so there are
identified as British that wouldn't be
surprising because British Special
Forces SAS the SBS are special boat
service and the special reconnaissance
regiment the srr I've got world-class
reputations for these sorts of things if
they're there my guess would be and it
is only a guess that they're beyond
reconnaissance because what makes them
special is not their ability to visit
paralyzing violence on the king's
enemies it's the ability to operate in
small units ones and twos and blend in
with the background just to sit there
without needing any other support for a
week two weeks three weeks and report
what they see and if they're in there
operationally that's the sort of thing I
would imagine that they would be doing
and could this lead lead to those
special forces if they are in there
being pulled out
um probably not I mean the Russians must
know that they're there they would
assume that Western special forces are
operational as their own special forces
would be operationally in other areas in
which the Russians are involved
elsewhere in the world
um I I think this will make a lot of
difference it's it's just that it it
raises the issue again sort of higher up
the agenda and the mod will just damp it
down saying well we don't comment what
about the whole issue of allies sharing
intelligence will Ukraine for instance
be less likely to want to share
sensitive stuff yeah that's always the
problem with these leaks and they happen
every now and again there's a spy
Scandal or a leak and it damages trust
between friends and of course you know
one of the things that these papers
indicate if that's true is that the
ukrainians were being spied on by the
Americans the zelinski's own
conversations were being reported
through signals intelligence not through
human intelligence but the Americans
have got great signals intelligence so
they can listen to so many conversations
all over the world and they do and it's
that trust has got to be rebuilt a
little bit so when we think about uh the
ukrainians getting you know the leopard
two tanks what are they going to do with
them of course the Americans are talking
to the ukrainians all the time but if
ukrainians have got some other ideas
about what they're going to do with them
the Americans would want to know if they
could